[Musique]
quelques idées de sorties à présent dans
ce journal dans moins de 15 jours c'est
noël pour beaucoup d'entre vous c'est
synonyme d'achats d'idées de cadeaux
aussi mais c'est aussi l'occasion de
multiplier les activités à vivre en
famille mélanie poker bonsoir en sarre
pour cette chronique à loisir vous avez
choisi de fêter noël de manière décalée
ce soir vous en avez fait un avant-goût
la semaine dernière avec votre à
invitèrent mélo brillé mais depuis l'an
dernier la commanderie de saint quentin
en yvelines propose un noël décalé des
activités plutôt originale pour
patienter avant les fêtes ce week end
pourrait notamment participé à des
ateliers de cuisine
non j'ai pas fourché charlotte blondel
professeur vous fait découvrir une
cuisine 100% végétale et surtout une
cuisine 100% crues ont fait patienter
les gens fait patienter les enfants
aussi
avant noël on a plein de d'ateliers
aussi pour l'heure pour offrir des
cadeaux pour se faire plaisir mais
différemment avec des associations
telles que vers et green à la verrière
qui va proposer des ateliers pour
fabriquer ses propres cosmétiques une
démonstration de sa palette de nombreux
ateliers donc avec un angle original
alors dominique délits menant à citer
que quelques-uns parce que bien sûr
c'est difficile d'être exhaustif mais on
peut rajouter d'autres création de
cartes de noël connectée du yoga en
famille des décorations de noël
mathématiques en origami et l'un des
ateliers vous permet même de faire des
dessins lumineux cemaf l'eau est pas
doué qui l'animent l'artiste
plasticienne est en création la
commanderie pour cette saison l'artiste
qui nous inspire aujourd'hui est un
artiste que j'ai découvert sur les
réseaux sociaux qui à partir d'objets de
son quotidien on observant les ombres
portées de ces objets s'est mis à
dessiner tout autour et on crée une
poésie
merci mélanie est lui aussi un temps
fort en ce week-end un marché solidaire
des créateurs et des associations vous
proposeront des produits de quoi donner
des idées au père noël pour garnir
garnir le pied du sapin et aussi de
nombreux marchés noël en programmes à
saint quentin en yvelines ce week-end
vous en parlerai dans votre émission le
7-8 ce loisir à suivre après ce journal